welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and whoo assassins
brings the star and action of the raid
to Netflix with the season that's one
hell of a kicker
throughout this video I'll be breaking
down everything that you need to know
about the show it's ending and what
could happen in season two there will be
heavy spoilers here so if you haven't
seen season one yet and don't want to
know what happens then I highly suggest
that you turn off now without the way I
just want to give a huge thank you for
quick in this video now let's get into
my breakdown of whoo assassins
we were SAS UNS follows chi a martial
arts expert also known as the chef who
finds himself embroiled in an ancient
war between the Wu Xing and mu assassins
two mystical groups that have secretly
fought in the shadows over millenia I'm
gonna try and keep this as simple as
possible as there's a lot to unpack from
it so I'll mainly be sticking to the
major plot points and trying to
pronounce them correctly from the off
the show introduces the dark side of San
Francisco with the Triads enforcing
their rule over the city Kai's father is
the leader of the gang and also a member
of the Wu Xing after Kai is given the
powers of the Wu the first season is
primarily focused on him learning to
hone his newfound abilities whilst also
stopping his father from taking over the
world though there comes some big power
plays in the season that drastically
changed the course of it this adds a lot
to the dynamics of the show but at its
core remains the battle between the two
sides which throws Kai to blows with his
father the Wu have mastered mystical
abilities built around several elements
and each of the ancient spirits
possesses and corrupts those that come
into contact with them they take their
power from the Dao which is sort of a
limbo between the real world and the
afterlife which is where thousands of
assassins who preceded Kai exist this
path comes into play in the ending of
the season and is where Kai begins to
master his abilities the path is devoid
of time and space and exists in a sort
of spiritual plane that the Wu are free
to enter however if someone steps into
it who's not been granted the correct
powers then this can cause disastrous
effects on reality kai is tasked by
ying-ying to collect the elements and
she saw it becomes his mentor from here
car goes throughout the season from one
to the next tackling the forces of evil
along the way whilst building a group of
allies made up of CG and undercover cop
Tommy his childhood friend his sister
Jenny and many more it's an amazing ride
that feels like the perfect mix between
comic book action and mystical magic
that delivers a martial-arts masterpiece
the show even makes chopping of
vegetables exciting and there's some
outstanding dynamism to the work this is
the bullet time of your life that
showcases some of the best fight
choreography that I've seen in the
better part of the last decade each
action set piece tops the last and it's
a thrill watching Kai take down whoosing
after losing in his quest to save the
world along the way he collected most of
the Wu and there's some big twists and
turns and changes of power mainly due to
the death of Kai's father who was
murdered by zan his trusted assistant
who takes over the gang kai was really
reluctant in fighting his father and
this death comes as a huge blow to him
this sends Kai on a quest for revenge
and it all comes to a head in the finale
when Kai is almost blackmailed into
giving up the wood whoo - Alex
McCullough Alec is a prominent gangster
and was holding Tommy in exchange for
the Wu which pretty much grants
immortality to the bearer left with
little choice kai tries to trick Alec
and gives the Wu - Tommy instead which
completes the circle and opens the path
Alec suspected that this would happen
which is why he decided to hold the
exchange at the ancient ritual site
which activates the opening that allows
him to reunite with his family that
doesn't mean it's all doom and gloom
though and inside it the whoosing is
removed from everyone and Kai is
seemingly able to bring them all
together as young Inge had done
previously Alec descends deeper into the
path and meets his family way finally
gets to spend some quality time with
them out in the woods think kingpin and
into the spider-verse
but with trees and you get the idea his
reunion is rather short-lived though
when he's pursued by Kai who manages to
kill him Kai spares Alec's family which
is when we get a huge time jump that
might leave some viewers confused we
find Kai back in the kitchen similar to
how we first met him in the initial
episode of the season and it appears for
the most part things are back to normal
zan has moved away to try and become a
more
a member of the Triads but everyone
sells down to eat some awesome Asian
food which is when yang Yang appears and
tells Kai that things are on over yet
the room begins to shake in this mantle
similar to the way that a dream
collapses in Inception and he get the
feeling that not everything's as it
seems so what does this mean well
personally I think that the entire time
like I believe things had returned to
normal that he was actually in his own
limbo similar to Alec and that the
ending of the season was all a
hallucination outside of the first
episode when yang Yang meets Kai
she only communicates with him on the
path so it makes sense that she would be
here at the end desperately trying to
crawl him back to reality before he
becomes lost in a dream there were
warnings in the season that the longer
someone spends in limbo that the more
damaging it can be on reality and as
Alec spent a long time in there it would
make sense that Kai's perspective could
be vastly altered to the point that he's
unable to distinguish between what's
real and what isn't so what will happen
going forward well personally I believe
that the second season will kick start
with ying-ying pulling Kai to the real
world and exposing that things in the
finale didn't exactly go the way that he
had thought the fact that Alex spent so
long in limbo has drastically altered
reality and the lines between the
dimensions are now massively blurred to
the point that we have once more made
their way to the world there is of
course an who will now be a prominent
figure in the Triads and will most
likely be wishing to fully take control
of the district no matter the means this
is why Kai is so essential and why
ying-ying had to go and get him because
his powers are needed once more whether
this happens or not remains to be seen
but there's a hell of a lot angel' that
could come in the future season I
absolutely love blue assassins and can't
wait to see what comes down the line as
this series has got me hooked
obviously I loved hear your thoughts and
we assassins and what you took from the
ending do you think Kai is still in
limbo or do you take the ending as yin
yang coming into the real world comment
below and let me know and if you enjoyed
this video then please like it and make
sure you check out my breakdown of this
week's our the big release scary stories
to tell in the dark would you be linked
at the end in it I go over everything
that you need to know about the film so
it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more if you want to
come talk to me about movies TV shows
games and come
books then you can follow me on Twitter
at definition YT it's the best way to
get in touch with me and it's the
perfect place to suggest new videos and
content so hopefully I see you over
there after this this is the channel for
people who are never missing television
so if that's the kind of thing you like
you need to subscribe to definition
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this you've been the best and I'll
see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
[Music]